bonsoir à tous et merci de nous
rejoindre pour ce nouveau numéro de 7,8
débat 10 euros c'est ce que vous coûtera
mon paquet de tabac d'ici à la fin 2020
une hausse programmée et progressive 3
euros en trois ans et ça augmente dès
l'année prochaine celle annonces du
gouvernement et de la ministre de la
santé agnès buzyn qui a comme ses brides
et ses prédécesseurs placé la lutte
contre le tabagisme comme une priorité
de santé publique
la nocivité du tabac n'est plus à
démontrer ces 78 mille décès par an en
france
fumer tue pour autant augmenter le prix
du tabac est ce la solution pour
dissuader les consommateurs répression
prévention c'est le débat du jour est
avec nous ce soir en plateau dorothée
baird sic au thérapeute et médecin
tabacologue face à vous jean-françois
vigour au président de la fédération
pardon des yvelines de la confédération
des buralistes et vous êtes vous-même
buralistes amant ou pas et renault
nadjani président du syndicat des
pharmaciens des yvelines
bonsoir à tous les trois bienvenue sur
ce plateau alors avant de commencer le
débat je vous propose de visionner
ensemble un micro trottoir réalisé par
axel d'eau est belle patrick jacques de
dixmude très bien aussi goûté ça peut
inciter les gens à ne pas fumer serait
une très bonne chose
non je crois pas pourquoi de toute façon
je les fais moi je vous fais mais les
fumeurs à ses récents peut-être que ça
peut les dissuader
et ça peut même dissuadé des jeunes ne
pas commencer à fumer en fait ça dépend
je les ferai peut-être venir de
l'étranger
on est deux à fumer donc arrêter du jour
au lendemain se compliquer voilà logique
par rapport à pousser les gens à moins
fumer si c'est plus cher je sais pas si
c'est la meilleure des idées des autres
moyens prévention chez pas de toutes les
façons les fumeurs restent fumeurs même
si on reste le tout ça il faut arrêter
de fumer
il faut arrêter de fabriquer tout à fait
normal ça coûte tellement cher à la
société ce tabak
le problème c'est que ça va augmenter le
le trafic de tabac quoi à l'époque du
franc c'était pareil on pensait qu'à 20
à 20 francs sur les gens allaient
arrêter de fumer finalement il continue
et je trouve que c'est une très mauvaise
chose sera absolument à rien ça va pas
empêcher les gens de fumer et si c'était
vraiment si néfaste que ça on
n'augmenteraient pas l'épreuve interdira
tout simplement donc je pense que j'ai
un petit peu d'hypocrisie dans la terre
voilà débat est lancé
alors cet homme qui nous dit ça ne va
pas dissuadé quel que soit le prix
un fumeur reste fumeurs jean-françois
vigouroux vous êtes buralistes une
profession qui opposait à cette
augmentation depuis quelques années le
prix du tabac ne cessent d'augmenter est
ce que à l'augmentation à dissuader les
consommateurs à dissuader vos clients
l'augmentation dit chad l'achat dans le
réseau officiel
surtout comme le disait la personne
interrogée sur le trottoir c'est que les
gens vont soutenir autrement donc et je
tiens à dire déjà qu'on n'est pas contre
une santé publique à une politique de
santé publique
mais je ne pense pas que ça sera avec
l'augmentation du prix qu'on a la boue
tira à l'orangé le phénomène est multi
genres surtout chez les jeunes
vous avez remarqué dans votre commerce
avoue peut-être une au xixe midi sur le
nombre de clients
oui depuis diminution chaque
augmentation bien sûr on sent une
diminution mais bon ça revient mais je
dirais que j'ai un nom comme commerce et
une brasserie et c'est la première année
que je m'aperçois autant de paquets de
marlboro sérigraphié malborough acheter
à l'étranger alors sur les marchés le
commerce transfrontalier
transfrontaliers et marché parallèle on
y reviendra un peu plus tard dans
l'émission de ruth hébert certains de
vos patients ont-ils décidé d'arrêter de
fumer justement à cause de cette
augmentation du prix du tabac
oui c'est une motivation très importante
à plusieurs titres d'abord parce que
c'est l'occasion parler du tabac ça
c'est une première un premier bienfaits
de cette de cette annonce et de cette
mesure
d'autres personnes sont effectivement je
vous rejoins sont effrayés par le par le
prix alors moi je vois plutôt les gens
effectivement qui ont décidé du coup de
prendre en charge leur santé leur
portefeuille et leur vie en fait et
d'essayer de transformer ce heures dans
une vie sans tabac
je rejoins ce qui a été dit aussi par
les différentes personnes qu on a
à vue là sur le micro trottoir on peut
travailler sur effectivement l'identité
du fumeur est ce qu'un fumeur reste un
fumeur c'est une question c'est une
vraie question
et ça se travaille au niveau santé
publique c'est vrai ça se travaille
surtout au niveau individuel avec la
percée vous avec vos patients c'est ce
que les fans avec nous passons des
patients c'est ce que je fais je suis
vraiment un bilan de qu'est ce qui les
motive donc l'entrée en matière peut
être l'augmentation du prix du tabac
mais vous avez eu une augmentation
justement peut-être un nombre plus de
clés de patients dans il ya
régulièrement des augmentations ça vient
par vagues et l'augmentation du prix du
tabac en est une donc oui il ya eu une
augmentation récente je pourrais pas
vous donner les chiffres parce que je
les ai pas
ça se regarde sur une plus longue
période bien sûr mais oui toute annonce
concernant le tabac
fait motif les gens à venir consulter
vous avez déjà des gens qui viennent
pour une rechute mais il ya aussi des
gens qui viennent pour une rechute bien
sûr will à la recherche fait partie du
processus d'arrêt processus de ré c'est
pas une seule fois et ça marche ou ça
marche pas c'est parfois un travail de
longue haleine
d'où l'intérêt et c'est vraiment aussi
se rendre service quand les patients
reviennent pour une rechute sais c'est
que ira si motivation sûr que barry
scheck pour un fumeur à gcc et ancien de
se faire aider par contre je pense qu'en
france il faut qu'on ait plus de
prévention
un peu comme en allemagne parce que en
allemagne ils ont droit au paquet
sérigraphié enfin aux normes européennes
il ya plus pour les jeunes il
ils ont plus de jeunes que nous et ils
ont moins de fumeurs donc quelque part
et le prix est moins cher donc c'est
encore une fois c'est pas le prix qu'ils
celui qui a envie de fumer tue moi rekom
et nous ce qu'on se bat c'est pour le le
trafic sur la prévention justement quel
est le rôle des professionnels de santé
comme vous dans cette décision
merci alors d'abord dire que
l'augmentation du prix n'est qu'une des
variables de l'enjeu et du programme
national de réduction du tabagisme
il y a aussi le l'éducation notamment à
travers des photos il y a aussi
l'interdiction des jeunes de moins de 18
ans il y a aussi l'interdiction de fumer
dans les lieux publics ou dans les
entreprises ont vraiment je crois que
c'est un ensemble d'éléments qui fait
qu'il ne pas oublier aussi la prise en
charge de
de sevrage tabagique en règle générale
la hauteur de 150 euros par an concert
qui peut être aujourd'hui les prix par
contre ça nécessite une prescription à
part identifié et serra et que les
infirmiers les kinés les chirurgiens
dentistes évidemment les médecins les
sages-femmes les sages femmes avec une
semaine plus étendue que leurs propres
comment dire patientes peuvent prescrire
à sevrage tabagique est évidemment que
le pharmacien au premier rang à travers
un arsenal thérapeutique important un
certain nombre d'éléments pour
accompagner cette cette décision qui est
une décision difficile qui est une
décision compliquée à tenir dans le
temps
je parle en connaissance de cause et que
effectivement on doit tous tous dans le
cadre de de notre attachement notamment
au compte de son de la santé publique
accompagner ce mouvement et puis aussi
pour vivre mieux et avoir une santé plus
importante 78 mille morts par an 13 13
millions de fumeurs 80% de cause du
cancer du poumon 17 cancer impliqué à
travers cette cigarette que l'on final
donc il ya un vrai sujet et qui devient
un sujet réellement de société et oui
tous les professionnels de santé sont
engagés sur cette prévention et cet
accompagnement dont le pharmacien
évidemment mais aux côtés de nos
collègues médecins bien évident alors
justement cette femme qui qui qui
déclare ça peut dissuader les plus
jeunes
alors effectivement rendre le produit
moins séduisant avec un paquet à 10
euros
des images choquantes tension les
paquets de cigarettes avec ça est-ce
qu'on peut avait évité la première
cigarette
dès le plus jeune âge ça peut décourager
qu'est ce que je sais enfin c'est à dire
que si les parents fument si tout le
monde fume à côté de ça il ya un peu du
mimétisme
donc il faut vraiment que ça soit je
vous dis l'éducation mais l'éducation
c'est pas l'école c'est aussi des
parents donc parce que l'école c'est une
instruction et l'éducation c'est des
parents donc je pense que vous montrer
le bon exemple
vous voyez beaucoup de gêne c'est que
des fois c'est même les parents qui
achètent des cigarettes pour les enfants
donc dans tous les tous les domaines
d'âge effectivement et pour les pour les
jeunes ce qui est difficile c'est que
ils sont pas très sensible au moins
sensible on va dire que le rsa
population aux messages de santé la vie
devant eux c'est normal et ça fait aussi
leur charme et leur dynamisme et leur
élan pour aller de l'avant
en même temps voilà toucher leurs
portefeuilles ça c'est un message par
lequel ils peuvent être touchés avant
d'être impactée ils sont déjà touchés
par la la communication effectivement
c'est un vrai handicap pour les jeunes
d'être d'être freinés dans leurs
dépenses et ça tient mon avis si les
parents qui payent s'appelle beaucoup
les parents qui payent
n'empêche qu'à un moment donné plus on
intervient tôt jeunes dans la dans la
sur la santé de quelqu'un ou plus on a
des chances que d'abord soit ils entrent
pas dans tabagisme
comment on fait ça c'est effectivement
une question compliquée et deuxièmement
c'est qu'on peut arriver à peu un
sevrage de cette jeune personne à
essayer de pas de garder son capital
santé du mieux possible réduire les
frais étaient rares voilà tout ce qu'on
a vu vous avez beaucoup de jeunes
patients donc j'aimerais peu de jeunes
j'ai quelques jeunes qui viennent
c'est ce pour lequel qui sont montre
plus de motivation ceux qui ont déjà une
difficulté de santé liés ou pas au tabac
mais pour lequel de tabac peut aider au
sevrage de tabac peut aider par exemple
et de cicatrisation à une guérison et
ses one asthme quelque chose de
chronique où effectivement le tabac un
impact direct mais non les jeunes qui
viennent directement pour arrêter de
fumer sans autre motivation
il y en a pas beaucoup reviennent à
l'état irlandais tentative c'était le
mois sans tabac laon
cette année à la deuxième édition en
novembre ça porte ses fruits ce type de
tirs a ajouté le mois sans tabac oui
globalement c'est une réussite il ya eu
six cent mille six cent vingt mille kits
qui ont été distribués alors les kits il
faut pas non plus se tromper c'est un
conseil par jour sur un mois pour ne pas
avoir envie de fumer ou avoir une bonne
raison d'arrêter de fumer
l'augmentation du prix alors il ya 180
mille inscrits sur le site dans le cadre
de et 3000 partenaires c'est pas rien
c'est pas rien c'est sa deuxième édition
et je trouve que ça va plutôt bien
j'aurais aimé et je crois que là ce que
je regrette sur le mois sont tabassés
que l'on sera pas en tant que
professionnels de santé plus appliquée
en amont et que l'on puisse organiser
les choses et que voilà encore la
chronique par la presse dieu merci vous
êtes là et que donc après on est
sollicité par les uns et les autres ce
serait bien que l'on soit un petit peu
plus dans cette démarche là et je
voulais dire que la meilleure façon
d'arrêter de fumer c'est de ne pas
commencer dès que l'occasion il me
semble et il me semble aussi qu'il est
important de remarquer une chose c'est
que les plus jeunes aujourd'hui
critiques les plus âgés de fumer dans
leur acte de deux fumeurs
les jeunes les plus jeunes aujourd'hui
je crois que ça commence j'en sais rien
mais en tout cas ça fait partie de leur
jeune ça le fait de jeter un mégot qui
qui polluent l'environnement
on entend régulièrement mais papa et
maman ne fait pas s'il ne fait pas ça à
fumer c'est pas bien arrête de fumer ça
c'est régulier aujourd'hui un donc je
crois que il y à une prise de conscience
et c'est bien donc on a réussi sans
aucun doute le l'élément essentiel de la
lutte contre le tabagisme qui est que
les futurs consommateurs sont de moins
en moins enclins à être consommateur et
ça je crois que c'est une très bonne
chose
maintenant il reste tout le reste à
faire encore une fois c'est un avion qui
craquent qui se crashe c'est
mondialement un problème là le tabac en
france
c'est un avion tous les deux jours un
avion tous les deux jours donc c'est un
moment il faut quand même mettre les
choses comme elles sont je rejoins
effectivement mal élevés différentes
choses qui ont été dites sur
l'augmentation du prix du tabac seul ne
résout pas touche
complètement d'accord avec vous c'est
l'ensemble de mesures ce que vous disiez
c'est le message qui rend
progressivement dans l'état d'esprit
général et notamment des jeunes et
vis-à-vis de leurs parents espérer que
ça et qui vont l'appliquer à eux-mêmes
ben tant mieux ça commence à généraliser
c'est un travail de longue haleine
donc effectivement sur des générations
comment savoir la première génération de
ce genre de mesures et deuxièmement il
n'y a pas qu'une seule mesure il y en a
plusieurs vous en avez cité un certain
nombre yann moix sans tabac il ya toutes
ces sensibilisations qui font que petit
à petit et mis bout-à-bout va y avoir
une efficacité et l'efficacité encore
une fois se mesure relativement court
terme sur le nom de fumeurs ou deux
personnes qui ont arrêté de fumer à un
instant t donc régulièrement des études
qui sont faites des
les enquêtes et deuxièmement se mesure à
beaucoup plus longue échéance sur le
nombre de patients qui sont malades et
qui meurt finalement ce que le critère
principal c'est l'homme de morts par an
guillaume damas et ça met un certain
temps à être mesurées en fait alors
beaucoup se demandent si c'est le rôle
c'est à l'état de jouer ce rôle
justement d'inciter les français à
arrêter de fumer
vous êtes d'accord pas d'accord écoutez
le rôle de l'état c'est d'essayer
d'améliorer la santé de l'ensemble des
des citoyens et que là dedans on est
bien en fait il ya des tas de mesures
qui sont fed qui sont prises dans un
certain nombre de domaines regarder la
vaccination grippe on est en pleine
période là aussi c'est c'est quand même
une prise en charge par la protection
sociale whissell d'après la santé
publique c'est quand même rôle régalien
de l'état
évidemment est évidemment que l'on doit
les uns et les autres qu'on se doit
d'accompagner ce mouvement là alors
notre notre président nous avait dit
dans son programme s'était attaqué à 10
euros qu'il voulait la mi mai il avait
quand même parler d'harmonisation des
prix de l'europe
le printemps c'est que quand vous allez
avoir un paquet à 10 euros en france et
qu'il est à 5 euros on va dire en
espagne au portugal
qu'allez vous faire parce que lorsque
vous êtes en vacances dans leur pays
basque vous allez jamais en espagne vous
n'avez jamais été en espagne à chaque
bouteille d'alcool jamais été faire un
plein en andorre j'avais acheté des
cigares et cigarettes qui peut le dire
aujourd'hui même pas manquer
justement de taper sur le buraliste
horizon va y mettre à 10 euros on va
perdre cinq mille buralistes d'ici 2020
c'est pas là c'est à dire que la
distribution du tabac est très
réglementée en france et beaucoup moins
vous allez en belgique c'est les
supermarchés du tabac alesina dimanche
je vais les voir ils ressortent à
illzach énormes et ils font quoi ils
viennent ils viennent en france et je
mets en france
ici ils sont malades site e-bay je suis
d'accord sur les autres pays et
notamment les zones frontalières où les
moments où on part en vacances ça c'est
une chose
cette collection commencée par quelque
part bien tirer les petites ficelles de
remporter le rhum mais après oui
certainement mais on peut pas le
problème se pose un geste un paquet à 10
euros au portugal alors que le smig
il a à 500 ans comprenez ce que je veux
dire c'est voilà l'europe a ses limites
on peut pas il ya des choses qu'on peut
faire et le couple pas et justement avec
5 quelle réponse on peut apporter au
consommateur en durcit entre guillemets
consommateurs en durcit alors d'abord
c'est quoi un consommateur en durcit ses
canaris taxe n'était pas possible s'ils
croient que c'est pas possible c'est que
déjà ils aspirent à acheter son paquet
de cigarettes en espagne
si le prix augmente s'il arrive à 20
euros par exemple mettons en france
continuera à fumer qu'est-ce qu'on fait
quelle réponse sanitaire
on apporte une réponse sanitaire sait
jamais c'est toujours pour le plus grand
nombre
c'est jamais 100% malheureusement c'est
comme ça il faut pas oublier qu'il ya
aussi la liberté individuelle qui fait
que ben on consomme consomme pas
certains produits on se fait du bien du
mal
voilà c'est très générale ce que je dis
et le tabac ont fait partie donc
effectivement je vous rejoins un temps
que le tabac restera la seule drogue
légale en france avec l'alcool pas tout
à fait la même addiction
ben oui ça restera un problème et on
peut pas on ne peut agir que sur le plus
grand nombre la santé publique c'est
agir sur le plus grand nombre et au
bénéfice du plus grande alors il ya cet
homme qui étudie dans le sujet ça coûte
cher alors le coût sanitaire et social
serait estimé à 120 milliards d'euros
ça coûte cher mais ça rapporte aussi non
et justement est-ce que c'est légitime
alors de voir cette augmentation avec
une approche budgétaire plutôt que
sanitaire budgétaire avant sanitaires
alors là on dit avant parce que depuis
la rentrée c'est la première mesure et
c'est peut-être aussi la première mesure
de ce gouvernement là je suis d'accord
après effectivement il ya des rapports
de pour des comptes
les deux derniers rapports notamment qui
disent que seul oui ça peut avoir un
impact de toute façon il faudrait
idéalement que le bénéfice
rangés par l'augmentation de ces taxes
sur le tabac soit mis au profit
justement de plus de prévention plus de
santé plus d'action puis directement
liés à la santé
je ne sais pas mais aujourd'hui c'est
dit est ce que j'y crois est ce que
c'est le plus classe du monde il faut
quand même pas oublier à 4 85% qui
revient à des fins illégales c'est bien
mais je sais bien maintenant une façon
je suis convaincu que si on commence pas
quelque part ne sont là que jacques
éponge
on ira n'est pas pourquoi il ya plus de
il ya beaucoup plus de fumeurs en france
que dans d'autres pays européens ou à
cape town guignard qui revient à l'état
n'oublions pas que le même état en face
il ya facteur 10 14 milliards de
recettes pour 120 milliards de dépenses
je pense qu'il ya quand même un problème
donc un en bois il va falloir quand même
régler ce problème qui est un véritable
problème pour interdire le tabac ça
serait la meilleure solution
je crois qu'il est interdit pas mal
d'endroits aujourd'hui oui mais
justement il ya cet homme c'est dans le
sujet éthique qui dit il faut arrêter de
fabriquer il pointe une certaine
hypocrisie la part de l'état c'est un
produit dangereux d'accord pourquoi ne
pas aller jusqu'à l'interdire qu'est ce
que vous pensez de cette perspective
purement hypothétique d'interdire le
tabac ça changera pas grand chose
l'artisan des cancers à libertés
individuelles il faut la défense et que
interdire pour interdire je ne suis pas
sûre qu'on y arrive
des drogues dures sont interdites la
consommation existent le problème c'est
de faire prendre conscience à l'ensemble
des personnes et notamment aux
consommateurs que finalement leur pire
ennemi ce même voilà et que cette
consommation là et tout à l'heure on
partageait avec dorothée si vous me
permettez avant l'émission qui disait
tout médecin si le patient n'est pas
avec moi je ne peux rien c'est
magnifique
il faut être au moins deux les soignants
seuls ne pourront rien l'état seul ne
pouvoir rien il faut qu'à un moment on
soit l'initiative et en parlant des jeux
je crois des jeunes je crois qu on est
dans cette démarche là et qu'il y à une
prise de conscience collective
ça durera un certain temps mais après
tout qu'est-ce qu'on en est par rapport
à l'humanité nous avec nos 80 ou où
s'entend d'espérance de vie rien
et qu'est ce qu'on va faire aussi avec
nos enfants par les effets que loulou
aujourd'hui on ne mesure pas sûr c'était
de consommation de tabac
c'est ça le vrai sujet combien ce que ça
coûte les patchs et autres substituts
pour beaucoup moins cher que la
consommation du tabac sur un mois alors
de mémoire rom et aux alentours
aux alentours les patchs aux alentours
de 30 35 euros donc vous voyez que sur
sur une période
enfin pour un mois de traitement donc on
est à peine un tiers de 2 du coût du
tabac
donc le problème encore une fois c'est
pas ça je crois que un moment voilà
duquel vous pouvez retirer en plus la
prise en charge qui est fait par la
protection sociale donc ça justement je
crois qu'il ya un certain nombre de
mesures qui ont été prises pour que le
prix ne soit pas un frein ne soit pas un
obstacle
voilà donc le tabac n'est pas remboursé
là il ya 150 euros par an
accompagnement donc ça couvre pas tout
mais après tout c'est aussi une décision
individuelle que de se protéger et
protéger sa propre santé et celle de son
environnement est celle de son
environnement
le fumeur ne fume pas tout seul il fume
dans une pièce où il peut y avoir des
personnes âgées des enfants
le conjoint ou la conjointe qui n'ont
rien demandé à personne et qui un jour
vont développer une maladie à cause du
du monsieur ou de la dame qui a fumé
dans la même pièce donc je crois que
c'est du civis aussi tout ça voilà on
est on est on est bien dans un mouvement
qui doit être un mouvement de la société
tout entière
alors il ya eu la cigarette électronique
[Musique]
avec les augmentations successives
il ya des périodes de mode qui
reviennent ça fonctionne chez certains
d'autres font un peu des deux les doutes
ni riche mais on verra dans quelques
années si les mets fins qui seront
certainement tête certainement pas les
mêmes en tout cas on verra si si les
problèmes sont au même endroit sur les
poumons
aujourd'hui quand vous dites on ne
connaît pas le
les méfaits on sait d'après des études
chimiques sur l'autre il ya moins de
substances toxiques dedans ça c'est sûr
il n'y a pas de monoxyde de carbone il
n'y a pas de combustion après comment se
déplacent en fait les consommations ça
c'est une chose moi je considère
qu'aujourd'hui la diva poteau instants
pour se distancier de la cigarette
donc la vaporeuse et n'est pas
aujourd'hui un outil médical ou de santé
pour ce
dons utilisés dans ce barrage tabagique
je ne le prescrit pas bien évidemment
ceci dit les personnes qui viennent et
qui me demande de quoi il s'agit comment
ça se passe et ce que je peux m'en
servir j'ai commencé voilà ce que j'en
pense je les soutenir dans leur démarche
parce que leur démarche de foncer je
veux arrêter je cherche un moyen et lava
porteuse est un moyen je vais
certainement pas les décourager
comme une personne qui me parlent
d'hypnose aux deux choses qui n'est a
priori pas quelque chose de 100% médical
au départ ou qui peut être fait par
d'autres que que les des professions
médicales
c'est de toute façon quelque chose qui
est nécessaire et utile en tout cas pour
cette personne à ce moment là il avait
peu de choses pour moi c'est plus qu'un
phénomène de mode
alors oui il ya des vagues je voulais
être avec vous effectivement il ya
différentes générations va poteaux sont
régulièrement on rentre dans un cycle et
tiens si j'essayais ce nouveau modèle où
cette nouvelle technologie est beaucoup
techno derrière donc ça peut plaire
aussi de ce côté là mais c'est plus
qu'une mode c'est aussi réellement pour
certaines personnes de laine et de toute
façon moi je considère c'est déjà une
prise de tête de distance par rapport au
tabac et que ensuite gérer les eaux
difficultés éventuellement les
transferts de difficultés qui sont du
coup transférer sur la batteuse
il ya beaucoup de personnes qui sont
avec cette interrogation l'inde qui sont
réellement dans cette situation on gère
plus tard on a le temps pour gérer ça de
la même façon les gens tunis - les pas
de chambre par je veux pas tomber d'une
addiction dans une autre d'abord népal g
addict au patch mais par contre on a le
temps de s'en occuper après alors voilà
donc la voie coûteuse c'est comme ça que
je l'intègre et c'est comme ça que j'ai
en tout cas j'en entends parler dans mes
convictions et je complète mon buraliste
aussi qu'ils sont
les dix ont aussi un autre conclusions
pour la fin on fait un tour de table je
commençais par vous passez du mot à mot
de conclusion sur cette thématique à
écouter
on attend de voir
les chiffres du paquet à 10 euros sur le
réseau on espère que
on va pas trop souffrir parce que
surtout à que tout ce qu'ils trafiquent
parce qu'il faut pas oublier non plus
que depuis le début de l'année il ya 45
camions de logiciels qui ont été braqués
et donc ça a disparu donc tout ça c'est
du trafic en amont et donc c'est dû
aussi du des ventes qui ne sont pas chez
nous donc entre le marché parallèle la
contrebande
voilà pour nous c'est très compliqué
écoutez moi je suis résolument comment
dire engagé sur l'accompagnement et la
défense de la santé publique donc tout
ce qui ira dans ce sens là évidemment la
lutte contre très bas de la vaccination
le dépistage la prévention
l'accompagnement sur la nutrition etc
je suis pour pour pourrait pour pourquoi
tout simplement parce que j'ai envie de
mes enfants et mes petits enfants vivent
dans un monde meilleur que celui que
j'ai le temps
merci à tous les trois des données sur
ce plateau fin du set 8 débat consacré
ce soir à la hausse du prix du tabac
l'émission est à revoir sur notre site
internet et a commenté vous le pouvez
sur les réseaux sociaux bonne soirée et
à la semaine prochaine
[Musique]